why do you guys think that women tend to  shame men for having standards  because they're old and bitter what do  you guys think I'm just curious like  because do we why do we say men yeah so  whenever whenever men have a standard  often and I'm not saying every woman  right but oftentimes women shame them  for having it so like we have the body  positivity movement right if guys I  don't like fat chicks  I've got to say I don't wanna I don't  want to date a single mother ah if they  say I don't want to date  ugly girls like anything that they say  they're shamed for  I think it's because we treat men like  trash  okay and we have too much higher  expectation of how they should treat us  and what they should be doing for us and  this and the other but we don't hold  ourselves in the same regard I